- Welcome everyone.
I'm currently here in the west of Germany
at a Sunday evening
and tomorrow on Monday,
we have a workshop with a
very important client of ours,
a client of Building Radar,
the company that I currently work for.
Here next to me is Leopold
another colleague of mine
also at Building Radar.
And in this video, I decided
to show you three things,
three things that we do.
The first, you can just
follow me along for the day,
see how we conduct the
client workshop tomorrow.
Thankfully, the client tomorrow agreed
that we can film also onsite.
But second, I will also share
some crucial tips and tricks
from our time here at Building Radar
but also before at consulting
on how to interact with clients
and conducting workshops.
And third, I would also
talk about some general tips
about being a manager
in a startup company,
interacting like that.
So we just finished working
on the document for tomorrow,
it's already quite late,
so we are about to go to bed, but Leopold,
thanks for joining me here.
I do not only know Leopold from work,
but we also met already during university
when we studied at our
undergraduate degree.
So I know that you had many
other opportunities as well.
You would also have had the opportunity
to go into consulting, into banking,
but you decided to start a business,
start a startup after university.
I trust many of you
also would be interested
to hear what was your rationale for that?
How did you think about that at that time?
- Yeah, first of all, Heinrich,
thank you for having me.
And really for me, it
all came down to impact.
Starting a startup is
really all about impact
during my time at
Google, I really noticed,
hey, this is really great
here, it's a nice tech company.
it's a fast changing environment,
but I just couldn't figure out for myself
what specific impact
I had for the company.
And I realized, really the only way
to have this impact you want
to have as an entrepreneur
is if you start your own company.
That's why I decided to
start Building Radar.
And our ambition really to
generate something big here.
- So we shot lots of material
at our workshop at Koster,
and we created a little
clip, a little mini video
to give an impression
how these workshops work,
what we do there and
how all this plays down.
So I will show you this video now
to give an impression of how
we do it at Building Radar.
Our mission at Building
Radar is to help companies
in the construction industry
to increase their revenue
with revenue engineering.
Many construction companies we talk to,
tell us that all of their functions
have very detailed sales processes
with the exception of the sales function.
This is of course surprising
because in the end of the
day, sales pays for the party.
Revenue engineering is the idea
that the sales process
can be broken down in
small steps, like a manufacturing process.
And then each individual
step can be trained
and can be improved in a systematic way.
When we work together
with new client of ours,
the starting point is
usually a workshop week.
In the workshop week, we
want to do three things.
First, we want to size
the revenue potential,
offer revenue engineering of this new
and innovative way to conduct proactive
sales for the organization.
To do that, we conduct interviews
in this workshop week
with different employees
of the company across hierarchy levels.
We also conduct a conversation
with the managerial accounting team
to collect all the necessary data
and also conduct interviews
with the IT department,
to understand all the dependencies.
As a result of that, we can come up
with a very clear picture
what the revenue potential
for that individual company
with the revenue engineering is,
over the next two years.
Second, we look at the organization
and capabilities of that client.
So from all the interviews,
conversations and other
data sources that we have,
we assess the current organization
and understand to what extent
it is already fit for revenue engineering,
or what the potential gaps are,
that still need to be
closed by the management,
by the team, in order to be successful
with revenue engineering
over the next two years.
Third, we jointly develop a roadmap,
how a successful path towards revenue
engineering can look like.
Here we distinguish all the individual
building blocks that this organization
needs to have in place
and still needs to come up
with in order to be successful.
We develop a timeline
how that could look like,
and we also show a different path
with different pathways out there,
how the folk would actually get there.
At the end of this workshop week,
we have a full day with
the senior leadership
of the company where we share
our preliminary results,
jointly co-create some
of the missing parts
that still need to be developed
and then jointly agree
on how the next steps
in the journey for revenue
engineering should look like.
Today, we conducted the last workshop day,
with the senior leadership of Koster,
which is one of the leading
general contractors in Germany.
We had a very productive day and exchange
and are very much looking
forward to the next steps.
Workshops are a key part
of working in consulting,
also many other
professional services firms.
And the key reason is
that usually you do not
just want to sit alone in the team room,
work on something for several months,
and then at the end of the project,
send over the results to the clients
because this will really not
help to really create buy-in.
So instead, what you want to do
is you want to co-create
results with your client
and surely workshops are
a great way to do that.
So let me share three
tips from our time here
at Building Radar but also
before in-consulting at McKinsey,
on what you can do to
improve your workshop game.
And the first is really to draw from many,
many different data sources,
information sources,
that then you bring to the workshop.
And what very few people only do,
but what is often extremely powerful
is to talk to other
employees of the company.
Because if you do that, what you achieve
is that then when you talk to the leaders,
the decision makers,
you can also tell them
what their employees told you.
And this clearly adds to your credibility
because the truth is that in many,
especially of these larger organizations,
the senior executives, the leaders,
they do not really know what
on an operational level,
all the people are doing.
They often have a certain
preconception of that,
but it's not always accurate
what they think of what is happening.
My second tip is about
creating the perception
with the client, that the
workshop was a success
and that some very, very tangible
results are coming out of that.
Because as a matter of truth,
if you just sit there, present something,
maybe ask a couple of questions,
ideally people will
have learned something,
but what most people will like even more
if the workshop really
created some tangible results
that they can then later use
and then build on and work with,
and what we like to do both in consulting
but also Building Radar,
is to in the workshop,
jointly develop things on the flip chart,
come up with decisions,
come up with results.
And then what we like to
do is after the workshop,
we create a document with
all the things we worked on,
all the things we can work with,
and then we distribute this document
with all the workshop participants.
And this makes it very tangible,
very clear what you
have jointly developed,
what the results were,
and this then often creates
the perception in your clients
that yes, the workshop
was not a waste of time,
but highly productive and
something came out of that,
which surely was worth
the time and the money
of all the people that attended.
My third tip is about how to make
the workshop a memorable experience.
And here, my key insight
that I learned over time
is that the more different types of media,
the more different types of formats
that you use in the workshop,
usually the better and the
better will be the memory
that people have about it.
And what I mean by that is the following:
So if the whole workshop consists
of you standing in front of the
crowd, presenting something,
asking questions, this is not
necessarily a bad workshop,
but what's often even better,
if then you have parts of the workshop,
which are conducted in
front of the flip chart.
Now you're standing there,
you're jointly developing something.
Maybe you even have another part
where you have a whiteboard or a poster,
where you elaborate something
that then comes together
written on the poster,
maybe you have some sticky notes
that people can write on
attached to the poster,
of course you should not do this,
only for the sake of doing this,
this should always also just add value
and make sense in the overall context.
But I would encourage you
to really think about that.
And just to add something on top
of just you standing
in front of the people
and presenting something.
So now I'm standing here outside
of our office here at Building Radar.
Hope today's video was insightful
to get some impressions at how we work
and what it is like,
and some tips on how to conduct strong
and successful workshops.
And as always, I wanna
say a big, big thanks
to all those sponsors and
members of the channel.
They're really making a big contribution.
Thank you for that.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please destroy the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the channel
to stay up to date on all the content.
My name is Heinrich.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
So see you soon next week,
all the best to you and bye-bye.